[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hello and welcome back
to Route 85, our show
for iOS developers,
because we love you too.
And the second part of our
series on how to open web
links in Google Chrome on iOS.
Now, in the previous episode--
which you should watch if you
haven't-- I showed you how to
detect if the user has Google
Chrome installed and how to open
a link in Chrome if they do.
But I'd like to explore
one other feature
that we haven't covered yet.
And it's the one that's
probably most important to you
app developers,
which is the ability
to add that nice little
Back button in Chrome that
takes users back to
your application.
I know it seems
like a small thing.
But going back to your
app with one press
as opposed to going through the
Multitasker, it's really nice.
Now, Chrome does this by
taking advantage of an emerging
standard in the iOS development
world called x-callback-url.
This is a convention
that allows applications
a little bit of
two-way communication.
What you're basically
doing is when
you open a custom URL
in another application,
within that URL you're also
telling the target app what
your own application URL scheme
is so that when the user is
done doing whatever they need
to do in that second app,
that application can open a new
URL with a custom scheme that
points back to the first app.
The whole thing's
actually pretty clever.
So what does this look
like in real life?
Well, let's take a look
at our Google Chrome URL.
Here it is.
It's pretty basic.
But now, instead of asking it
to open the host www.google.com,
I'm going to ask it to open
the host x-callback-url.
This is basically the
signal to Google Chrome
that, hey, I'm going to give
you some information using
the x-callback protocol
so that you can swap back
to my application
when you're done.
After this, I'm going
to add the action open
And then pass in a
URL argument called
url that equals the
link we want to visit--
or I guess more accurately, the
URL encoded version of that.
So you end up with something
that looks like this.
Now, if I were to actually
open this URL it would work.
In fact, let's try this right
now in our sample application.
So here we are back in
my OpenInChromeExample
application.
And I'm going to
create a new URL along
with the Safari and
Chrome URL that I
am going to call my callbackURL.
And it's going to look fairly
similar to my Chrome one.
I got this URL, URL string.
Except that my string here
is going to be googlechromes.
But then for my host, I'm going
to go with x-callback-url.
I'm going to add the action
open and then I'm going to say
url=https://www.google.com.
Now, this won't quite work
because I need a-- yes, Xcode,
I know I need a
semicolon-- because I
need to URL escape these
three characters here.
So let's do that as well.
This should be : / and /.
Does anybody know if
Xcode will automatically
URL escape strings for you?
If so, let me know
in the comments.
So anyway, lastly,
I need to make sure
that I replace my Chrome URL
here with my callback URL.
Oh and I guess it'd be nice if
I spelled URL correctly, huh?
Wouldn't that be nice?
Let's fix that.
Edit All in Scope.
And I'll change that to URL.
That's better.
Now I can run this on my device.
And when we click
on this button,
we can see that, yes,
my URL opens in Chrome.
But there's still no Back
button pointing to our app.
And that's because
we haven't actually
told Chrome anything about
the app that called it.
Now, in order to
do that, we need
to register our own URL scheme.
The same way that
Chrome declares
that it owns any URL
beginning with googlechrome,
we can declare our own custom
URL scheme for our example app.
So let's do that now.
I'm going to go
back to Xcode here.
Let's open the project
and check out the target.
And over here in the
info section down here
at the bottom, there is this
section called URL types.
This is where our application
can declare any URL schemes
that it can open.
So let's expand this.
And right now
there's nothing here.
But let's click the
plus sign and add one.
So identifier here is a
human readable version
of our URL scheme.
Most developers that
I know just seem
to make this their bundle ID.
So I guess I'll do the same.
So
com.google.openinchromeexample.
And of course, feel free
to replace com.google
with whatever is appropriate
for your organization.
Now, URL schemes here,
this is the string
that is going to
go before the colon
that we say we are going to own.
Now, this should be unique
for your application.
Now, if you're an application
like Chrome or Google Maps
that's expecting to be called
by many other third-party apps,
you could try something like a
variation on your application's
name.
But if you're really
only registering
this URL for
situations like ours
where we're going to be
telling the target app what
our URL scheme is and we don't
expect a lot of third party
developers to know it, I
think it's generally safest
just to use your bundle ID,
maybe without the periods.
So we'll do
something like this--
comgoogleopeninchromeexample.
I need to make sure
I spelled this right.
Yeah, it looks good.
I'm going to copy this because
we're going to use it later.
So now we've
declared that any URL
that begins with
comgoogleopeninchromeexample
colon whatever will open
up in this application.
So now that we've
done that, let's
go back to our callback URL.
I'm going to open up
ViewController.m here.
And here's our callback URL.
And we're going to modify this.
So I'm going to continue
this on another line
because we're getting
a little crowded here.
And the first thing we're going
to do is add an &x-source=My
App argument.
So this is a human
readable version
of our application name.
And in Chrome's case it's
going to use this value
to determine what text to put
in that little Back button.
And again, we need
to URL escape this.
So I'm going to replace
that space with a .
The next thing we're going to
do is add an x-success argument.
Now, in the
x-callback world, this
is a URL that our
target app will
attempt to open once the user
is done doing whatever he wanted
to do in that app and things
have proceeded normally.
Note that in Chrome's
case it's going
to use this URL whether or not
the page you're trying to open
has actually opened or whether
it's gotten a 404 or whatever.
It's always going to
use this success value.
So for the value of
our success argument
we're going to set it to
a URL that points back
to our app, which in this
case is our custom scheme.
And luckily I copied it.
So I'm going to paste it here,
comgoogleopeninchromeexample
with a colon at the end.
And again, that colon
needs to be escaped.
So I'm going to
replace it with a :.
And so now we have this
much larger URL but one
that has an x-source argument
and an x-success argument.
So let's try running this
now and see what happens.
So I'm going to click
this button now.
And looky here.
It's open in Chrome.
And now there's
this Back button.
The title is equal
to My App, which
is what we specified
as our source.
And when we click on it, it now
goes back to our application.
So that's pretty awesome.
Incidentally, if you notice that
your Chrome browser does not
have a Back button, the
most common reason for that
is that what you've
added as your x-success
URL here does not
actually equal what
is in this URL types
URL scheme section.
Chrome does its
own UI application
Can't Open URL check to
determine whether it should
display that Back button
in the first place.
And if this value
in the URL scheme
does not match what
you have put in here
in your x-success
argument, it'll say,
oh no, I can't open that URL.
And it just won't
show the button.
So let's review that giant
URL one more time here.
Whoa!
So the Google Chrome URL
scheme at the beginning
is asking us to
open Google Chrome.
The x-callback URL
host is warning Chrome
that it's about to
receive an argument
in the x-callback URL form.
The open action followed
by the URL argument
is telling Chrome what
page to actually visit.
And the x-success
argument is telling
Chrome what URL scheme to
open when it's all done.
And finally this
x-source argument
tells Chrome what text to put
in that little button that
takes the user back
to your application.
So this is great.
But we're not done yet.
See, it turns out
everything we've just done,
it doesn't actually
work if you've
got a version of Chrome
that's a few years old.
Admittedly, not a common
situation these days,
but it could happen.
And let's face it.
Our code is starting to
look a little messy here
and it might even get
messier before we're done.
But not to worry.
We're going to deal with both
of these problems in the very
next lesson.
So stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]